and we're going to start in atlanta
because there are fears this morning
that a string of deadly shootings at
massage parlors in the atlanta area
could be linked to a wave of attacks
against asian americans
eight people were killed in the city and
at least one wounded in those attacks
yesterday night
and at least half of the victims are
believed to be asian women
the suspect arrested 150 miles away
after a chase is a white man his name is
robert aaron long
that is his picture there mark
straussman is at one of the crime scenes
in atlanta
mark this story is so troubling and
terrifying at the same time good morning
to you
good morning gail three of the women
were killed at the gold spa behind me
police say it's too soon to tell whether
victims were targeted because of their
race
but the shootings do come during a
pandemic error surge in hate crimes
against asian americans the shooting
spree began around 5 pm monday
at young's asian massage parlor in
cherokee county 30
miles north of atlanta two victims died
at the scene
two more at the hospital
less than an hour later police were
called to gold spa an atlanta massage
parlor
where police say three women who
appeared to be asian had been shot
and killed while at that at that
location we received another call across
the street had shots fired
that location was aromatherapy spa
where another victim who also appeared
to be an asian woman
died it's just unfortunate it's not
really making any sense how this happens
at
a massage spa the common thread
connecting the shootings
prompted an atlanta police officer to
radio in this warning
we need to make sure we have any asian
spots
a manhunt began for the suspect seen in
surveillance footage
driving a black hyundai earlier in the
day georgia state patrol troopers
performed the pit maneuver
which caused the vehicle to spin out of
control officers later captured
21-year-old robert aaron long
150 miles south of atlanta
now relatives of the shooting victims
are left grappling over why
this happened i was just thinking how we
never know when we're at the wrong place
at the wrong time because this was so
all of a sudden and it just it was just
like a lot of things racing through my
head
overnight the south korean foreign
ministry told cbs news that
four people killed were of korean
dissent
several advocacy groups warned that
these shootings are likely to heighten
fears among all asian americans
i mentioned earlier the spike in hate
crimes against them by one estimate
a 150 percent increase in those crimes
last year
anthony just disturbing on so many
levels yeah on so many levels mark thank
you one group is calling for immediate
action even though
we do not know for sure that this is a
hate crime in a statement
that group stop asian american and
pacific islander hates says there have
been
nearly 3 800 reported hate incidents in
the u.s
since march of last year and of course
president biden singled out violence and
hate against asian americans
during his time prime time speech to the
nation just last week
this is very concerning i mean given
everything we now know
uh about what's been going on yeah and
we have to keep saying we don't know for
sure but
let's just say this the signs look very
troubling so much as they even that
the police officer said listen if we
have any asian spas we need to be
we need to be on the lookout for them
and even as we await
upsetting even as we await word from law
enforcement we can't say definitively
this will only deepen fear in the asian
community
exactly